hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
it's a distant fact now but Enron was
once the seventh largest corporation in
America they revolutionized trading and
the energy market there were far smarter
than their competitors and their
business was intricate and too complex
for the average person to understand
except in reality it was all a big scam
filled with lies
fraud and political manipulation Enron
was the biggest scam in US history the
fallout from the scam was monumental
billions of dollars stolen thousands of
lost jobs
dozens of convictions one suicide and
the unveiling of a very public display
of corporate greed that shined directly
into the heart of corporate America this
is the story of how one company took ten
years to grow to sixty billion dollars
in value and then in less than a month
go bankrupt this is the story of Enron
you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
Enron began as an energy supply company
mainly dealing with natural gas
eventually the company moved on to
trading making energy deals in power and
then later
moving on to broadband and even trading
the whether there were Wall Street's
darling the company that could never
lose and a stock price kept growing
year-on-year the company was also
well-connected politically for example
Enron was the single biggest contributor
to the George W Bush campaign Bush even
called Kenneth Lay the founder of Enron
Kenny boy and it's with Kenny boy that
the story starts
growing up in a poor family Kenneth
Leia's father was a Baptist priest the
young Ken would often ponder about his
future a future where he could escape
his current conditions when he grew up
he became a prominent figure in the
deregulation of the energy sector the
PhD graduate spent his time as a
financial analyst in the Pentagon before
climbing the ranks and becoming close
friends with George Bush Senior Ken Lay
would even send the Enron corporate jet
to take George senior and his wife to
their sons inauguration as you will see
later these favors did not go unruhe
[Music]
the first red flag the founder of the
company Kenneth lay the something was
wrong within the company came during the
valhalla scandal of 1987 to oil traders
working for Enron gambled enormous Lee
on the company's behalf shifting money
to fake accounts with names such as my
ass or my ass worried auditors told lai
that they found the two traitors moving
money into their own accounts
manipulating earnings and gambling on
trades beyond their capacity but instead
of firing the two road traders lai made
no changes didn't seem to matter what
they were doing as long as they were
making the company money and run even
sent them a letter saying please keep
making us Millions
later the two were convicted of fraud
Ken Lay acted shocked saying that he was
not aware of their reckless gambling and
theft but as revealed later he actually
encouraged it one of the convicted
traders was sent to jail for a year and
this gave Ken Lay a big problem one of
his main moneymakers was behind bars and
he needed someone new to bring in cash
enter Jeffrey Skilling
[Music]
skilling Enron's new CEO was leis
biggest asset when he arrived at Enron
he started moving the company in a new
direction
skilling wanted to turn Enron from a gas
supply company into a stock market for
natural gas he also introduced the
company to mark to market accounting an
idea that would allow the company to
fraudulently reap billions so
mark-to-market accounting simply allows
the company to write down profits in
their books on the day that the deal was
signed this meant that if Enron signed a
deal worth 50 million dollars over the
next 10 years they could write 50
million dollars in their books that day
despite not receiving a penny it didn't
even matter if the deal fell through
effectively this myth of the company was
worth more on paper than it had actually
earned the deals were often subjective
they could be worth whatever Enron
thought they were worth when the
Security and Exchange Commission
approved the accounting trick of
mark-to-market for Enron the office
celebrated they knew that this was the
key to making billions meanwhile
skilling was known for his Darwinian
philosophy survival of the fittest his
favourite book The Selfish Gene
describes how greed and competition
motivate human nature at Enron skilling
wanted to unlock these instincts in his
employees one way he did this was
grading all employees on a scale of one
to five with one being the best and five
being the worst the thing was 10% of all
employees had to be greater to fire and
when you were graded a five you were
fired this created the competition that
skilling was looking for people began to
work 18 hours a day and were ruthless in
their efforts to earn the company as
much money as possible skilling famously
said that money was the only thing that
motivated
unsurprisingly skilling was a massive
risk taker he often went on wild
adventures with other Enron executives
this includes dirt biking on dangerous
trails where people often flip their
cars an executive even required stitches
after a biking accident on one of these
trips skilling said he liked guys like
this guys with a bit of edge Lao PI a
mild-mannered executive was one of these
guys with a bit of edge
skilling called Lao PI is ICBM
intercontinental ballistic missile
he will CEO of an Enron subsidiary and
seem to be motivated by two things money
and strippers PI isn't as mysterious
thing as one can be in such a huge
scandal he left and on in 2001 with 215
million dollars became the second
largest landowner in Colorado
he left his business division with 1
billion dollars of losses and escaped
the whole scandal pretty much intact pi
would come back later into this story a
few decades after the dust settles Enron
online will change the markets for many
many commodities it is creating an open
transparent marketplace that replaces
the dark blind system that existed it is
real simple to turn on your computer and
it's right there and if you want to do
business you push the button
that's our vision and we're trying to
change the world
[Music]
and it wasn't just Internet companies
feeling the fever and run stock had
tripled in the space of two years
everyone with a little bit of spare cash
was playing the stock market game and
run knew that as long as the company met
or exceeded endless expectations the
stock price will keep rising and somehow
they always met or exceeded those
expectations during this time while Jeff
Skilling stood at the company's
conventions telling his staff to put
more of their 401k in to Enron he knew
that the profits were actually going in
the opposite direction around the world
they were losing billions on natural gas
projects Enron had poured billions of
dollars into appliance in India you need
to realize that India couldn't afford to
buy the electricity the site lay in
ruins but that didn't stop the
executives at Enron writing down future
profits for the project into their books
and handing themselves massive bonuses
the analyst the very people who were
supposed to stop the corruption fell
under the spell of skilling the
complexity of the company and the
charisma of skilling made analysts
simply take him at his word in fact the
ones that didn't were fired the company
soon began trading bandwidth after some
calm inspiration they made a deal with
blockbuster to provide streaming
services but the technology just simply
didn't work well enough yet the deal
fell through but Enron still rode fifty
three million dollars in their books for
things began to get out of control and
Enron soon began trading weather
yes the weather like sunshine and rain
they would soon sell futures on the
weather essentially gambling what the
temperature would be you would probably
imagine that most people would be
skeptical of this but it was activities
like this that led and run to being
listed on the fortune 500s most
innovative companies list but one
reporter at fortune would soon start
asking questions and this would later
lead to the company's demise Bethany
McLean a reporter at fortune was doing a
piece on Enron she had a phone call with
John skilling where she asked some
simple questions like how exactly does
Enron make its money
skilling said he couldn't answer because
he wasn't an accountant so he sent a few
finance guys including Andy fust our the
CFO to answer her questions the next day
they sat in the office for three hours
poring over documents at the end as
others had left the room and he turned
to the reporter and said I don't care
what you write about the company just
don't make us look bad Andy Foster was a
character described as having no moral
compass
he made Enron deaths disappear by moving
them to show companies so that on paper
and run was profitable he even set up
his own fraudulent firm just to buy an
Iran assets this fraudulent firm was
called ljm Andy would later convince
ninety-six bankers to invest in the scam
ljm firm ljm would make Andy Faust our
forty five million dollars but it seemed
to that the banks were in on the deal
too
Merrill Lynch bought three Nigerian
barges from Enron and sold them back
five months later this was to help
anyone cook their books and later
several bankers would go to jail for
this both skilling him lay knew that
even this couldn't last forever they
needed a new gold mine and then they
turned their eyes to the Golden State
California now skilling became
increasingly volatile arriving at work
unshaved and retired on a 2001 investors
call he even called an investor in a
hole a brash reaction from a fortune 500
CEO the pressure was getting to him
the company had to keep making quarterly
targets
despite their businesses failing at home
and abroad California was going to be
their next big score Enron merged with
Pacific Gas & Electric which gave them
access to the Californian grid once this
was achieved strange things began to
happen in the newly deregulated
electricity market of California rolling
blackouts became common but strangely
the state had almost doubled the
capacity than there was demand so why
was this happening it turns out Enron
traders were manipulating the market
they moved electricity out of state to
increase demand and when the price got
high enough they would move it back in
they even called power plants and asked
them to make excuses to shut down for a
few hours increasing the price as those
less demand traders had energy maps and
the control to move the energy they knew
exactly how to squeeze every last dollar
from the people of California while the
state faced blackouts causing unknown
holes on the lives of Californians the
Enron traders were high-fiving
themselves over their bonuses Ken Lay
even said it doesn't matter how many
rules you Californians make I've got a
bunch of smart people here that will
figure out how to make money anyway the
year-long ordeal would cost California
30 billion dollars but why didn't the
state put a stop to it well the law
states that it's the federal government
issue and it's their responsibility to
take care of it and guess who the
president was at the time that's right
leis good friend George W Bush Bush
refused to step in saying that it was
his administration's belief that
intervention would not solve anything
the Federal Energy Regulation Commission
also didn't step in until the Senate
forced them to the chairman of the
Commission was personally recommended by
Kenneth Lay this whole ordeal caused the
people of California to turn on their
governor and appoint a new one one that
was more suitable for the role the
Terminator
one day in 2001 out of the blue skilling
suddenly resigned
perhaps he figured he could leave the
company years before it imploded then he
could say well it was fine when I left
it regardless
Kenneth Lay took over the CEO role just
one day later Sharon Watkins who worked
under the company CFO Andrew foster sent
a letter to Kenneth Lay detailing the
staggering amount of corruption and
fraud that she'd found within the
company The Wall Street Journal would
write a piece about some of Andy's
dealings and soon the SEC would launch
an informal inquiry at this point
investors began to feel nervous Kenneth
Lay tried to bring calm and reassurance
to investors and employees while he was
addressing the company's issue to a
speech to employees to several blocks
away and runs accounting firm was busy
shredding documents one of the
accounting firms shred one ton of paper
on October the 23rd but it was too late
the walls began to fall and over the
course of a month the company went from
that healthy appearance of one of the
leading innovators to total bankruptcy
you want us to believe that you sat
there in your office and didn't and had
no clue that this place was about to
collapse
on the day I left on August 14 2001 I
believe the company was in strong
financial condition I did not do
anything right that was not in the
interest and all the time I worked for
an run corporation that was in the
interest of the shareholders of the
company if I could go back and redo
things I would not know
for the thousands of people who held
Enron stock the market was frozen at the
$32 mark and when it reopened it was
nine dollars a share meanwhile andron
executives had a fire sale of all of
their stock in the months leading up to
the bankruptcy skilling told his
employees to blame or stock while he
sold all of his as the media began
circling the story criminal
investigations were launched cliff
Baxter a trader who often went on
Skilling's wild adventures cashed in 30
million dollars from Enron after being
called to testify in court
Baxter Cod in his Mercedes drove down a
quiet street and shot himself
Andy Foster the former CFO pleaded
guilty to conspiracy to commit wire
fraud he ratted out and cut himself a
deal to testify against other Enron
executives he was sentenced to 10 years
but only served six and paid 23 million
in fines and runs accounting firm Arthur
Andersen the one that shredded one ton
of paper was convicted of obstructing
justice America's oldest accounting firm
collapsed due to the loss of reputation
29,000 people lost their jobs
Ken Lay earned 300 million from Enron he
was found guilty of 10 counts of
securities fraud and was facing 45 years
in prison but died of a heart attack a
month before his sentencing 20,000
people at Enron lost their jobs and
medical insurance with an average
severance pay of only $4,500 executives
were paid 55 million dollars during the
bankruptcy and cashed a further 774
million in the year before the collapse
skilling the mastermind behind Enron was
convicted of 19 counts of security and
wire fraud he was sentenced to 24 years
and 180 million in fines while in jail
his parents and his son passed away
I only served 12 years of his 24 year
sentence and was released in early 2019
but this isn't where the story ends
[Music]
skilling is hoping that he can get a
second chance he appears to be applying
a return to the energy sector only two
months after his prison release in early
2019 skilling was entered as a manager
of a new company which he founded a few
years ago Lau PI / former Enron
executive who sailed off into the sunset
with us 250,000,000 is reported to be
helping skilling regain connections and
funding according to The Wall Street
Journal skilling has been holding
meetings from former Enron executives in
relation to starting a new venture this
may be difficult for him as obviously
his reputation has been massively
smeared
but apart from people's perception
there's technically nothing stopping him
the SEC has banned skilling from being
an officer if any public company so as
long as this venture stays private he
can do whatever he wants so that is the
story of Enron with a not so typical
ending despite being one of the biggest
players in the biggest scam in the US
history resulting in billions of dollars
in losses for average people tens of
thousands of lost jobs and executives
reaping and billions skilling is out of
jail and free to start again
Enron's motto was asked why during his
astronomical rise it seemed that no one
bothered to ask why how or where the
money was coming from and now with
skilling out of jail and trying to
re-enter the business world maybe once
again we should ask why
[Music]
so that wraps up our look at Enron
thanks for watching this video I hope
you enjoyed it if you want to see stuff
like this or much more you should
definitely consider subscribing to this
channel if you want to see my last video
on business fraud which was the fairness
story I'll leave a link for that after
this interestingly enough Elizabeth
Holmes as dad was a former executive at
Enron I'll say no more anyway that's it
thanks for watching this has been - gogo
and you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll see you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's me thinking
[Music]
you